This is a glimpse of what the future may look like.
The goal is to have a very affordable, very economical to operate...
...but still a very dependable vehicle.
This car built by Ron Cerven and his Li-ion Motors team...
...is one of 136 vehicles from around the world...
...that competed for the $10 million prize.
The objective: design a car that is fuel-efficient,...
...safe, environmentally friendly and affordable.
Brad Jaeger of the team Edison2.
To have an impact on the world,...
...the car not only has to be more efficient and get good fuel mileage,...
...it has to be cheap.
After going through rigorous testing,...
...the competitors were narrowed down to a few, showcased in Washington.
The top three cars shared the big prize.
Ron Cerven says it's hard to believe his team won the prize.
It's two years' worth of work summed up in a day and I just don't think you can do it.
I think it'll take longer than that to really kind of get the feel for what we did here.